talks will resume in Switzerland in a
few hours to try to finalize a deal to
curb Iran's nuclear program a midnight
deadline passed without any agreement
and then the meeting broke up a few
hours ago well russia says there was an
agreement on all key aspects but the US
said not all issues have been agreed we
spoke to the national security analyst
arish era measures in Washington the two
sides are at a Mexican standoff they're
staring at each other for days and days
and days to see who's gonna blink first
but it seems like the two sides have
reached a framework to agree on the big
issues on the one hand we heard from
Sergei Lavrov the Russian Foreign
Minister and the french Foreign Minister
that a lot that they have reached a deal
on the under general framework javad
zarif the Iranian Foreign Minister just
tweeted something along the same lines
about an hour ago but an unnamed senior
US official also said that there are
some issues that have remained not every
issue has been resolved so we're getting
some conflicting contradictory reports
coming from Switzerland but it seems
like that the two sides really wanted to
get a deal it seems like the two sides
have hashed out some of the key
differences but we're still not sure
what the actual details of this deal
contain will find that out as soon as we
get this detail and a press conference
from the sides no one knows what's going
to happen from now till later today this
situation is very fluid it can change
any minute but stakes are high for both
sides it seems that they have reached an
agreement at least on the larger key
issues that is Iran's activities and
sanctions on the ability of Secretary of
State John Kerry and President Obama
being able to sell this at home that's
gonna be a tough sell we don't know what
the deal entails if the deal is
something that puts severe limitations
on Iran's nuclear capability well they
will have an easier time at the at home
in Congress to sell it but let's not
forget President Obama is dealing with
an opposition Congress and very very
strong opposition Congress with
significant historic Republican
majorities in both the House
and the Senate and a leadership in both
the House and the Senate that has shown
to be very against this deal we saw that
a couple weeks ago they invited Prime
Minister Netanyahu to come here they
defied the White House so this is not
gonna be an easy sell even if it's a
good deal for the United States if it's
a bad deal there might be some other
legal issues and legal hurdles and
political challenges that the
administration is going to face but
regardless the Republican Party and the
Republican opposition is going to give
this president a challenge his money's
worth